in modern culture women are an
antidepressants women are depressed more
than ever in human history but if it's
traditional right no matter whatever
culture it is you you can't get out even
if you want to get out you can't get out
because you're gonna think oh what about
my family what would the culture say
yeah and that's and that's better
because that was when mothers put their
kids before them it wasn't a me me
culture it's not about my happiness
about your kids your kids more likely to
go to prison they're more likely to be
in a mental institution they're more
likely to drop out of school you're
putting your kid at every statistical
disadvantage you can possibly put them
at by leaving every statistical
disadvantage
don't care because they care about their
feelings and not the kids